JOHN: Good morning, Hank, it's Tuesday. So
VidCon was fun - so fun, in fact, that I took
hardly any video except for this (audience
screaming).
JOHN: Hello, VidCon!
JOHN: Anyway, it was basically like that level
of sensory input for 72 straight hours, but
before VidCon, I was on a television program
called "The Colbert Report," which meant makeup.
JOHN: So, I am completely, really, super-into
getting my makeup done.
MAKEUP ARTIST: You are?
JOHN: Have I told you this yet?
MAKEUP ARTIST (laughing): No.
JOHN: I'm John, by the way.
MAKEUP ARTIST: John, I'm Bridget.
JOHN: And, yeah, I think - I had my makeup
done on the whole - the whole time I was on
the movie tour.
BRIDGET: Okay.
JOHN: Like, first thing in the morning, then
they'd touch it up all day long.
BRIDGET: Right.
JOHN: I just looked so good. I felt so good
about myself.
(Bridget laughs.)
JOHN: I'm not even kidding.
BRIDGET (laughing): That's awesome.
JOHN (to Hank): So while Bridget does my makeup,
Hank, a few makeup thoughts. I confess that
in high school, I was one of those guys who
was like, "You don't need to wear makeup.
You're beautiful just the way you are." Meanwhile,
of course, I was covering my body in carefully
selected clothes every morning, showing that
on some level, I did understand that humans
generally don't present themselves in public
"just the way they are."
Now obviously, TV makeup is different from
everyday makeup, but here's what I like about
makeup. One, it feels good. It feels good
to touch your face gently and kindly. Two,
it's like really beautiful armor because it
makes me feel more confident and, somehow,
kind of protected as I go through my day.
It's sort of like wearing my favorite outfit,
except I can do it every day.
Three, Hank, as you know, I am a massive hypochondriac,
so I don't like to touch my face because that's
how disease spreads. But I find that I actually
touch my face less when I'm wearing makeup
because my face is not, like, dry and itchy
and et cetera.
Four, I like the way I look. It's pretty simple,
actually. Hank, when I was younger, I basically
thought that women wore makeup for men, which
speaks to a sick and very deep part of the
patriarchy in which men imagine that women
orient themselves toward attracting men, instead
of having, like, meaning and pleasure inside
their own lives that has nothing to do with
dudes.
But when I wear makeup, I genuinely don't
derive pleasure from thinking about how I'll
look to people watching me on TV or whether
it will make me more attractive to other people
- I just like the way I look. It makes me
happy. Now, of course, lots of people don't
like wearing makeup, which is totally cool,
but I do!
That noted, I'm probably not going to be wearing
makeup on a daily basis, partly because I'm
lazy, partly because I am tragically un-immune
to social conventions, and partly because
I've been totally spoiled by having my makeup
done by amazing professionals like Bridget.
But this whole experience has made me a tremendous
fan of makeup, and also of the YouTube makeup
tutorial, so I put some links to my favorites
in the doobly-doo. And Hank, I also have to
say that I think you are super-cool for having
worn makeup in high school.
Okay, now it's time for my big reveal!
JOHN: Do I look all right? Do I look like
my regular self, but better?
SARAH: Mm-hmm. Yeah.
JOHN: Perfect.
JOHN: Hank, congratulations on VidCon. I hope
you're getting some sleep. I will see you
on Friday.